This part of an MLM helps
with a radiologic study that
involves injecting the patient
with a contrast dye
to better see the functioning
parts of their internal organs.
It deals with a lab test, the creatinine
level, which measures kidney function.
This is important, because the dye in
the study is removed by the kidneys, but
it can also cause kidney damage.
So it's important to know the patient's
kidney function before giving the dye.
To check for that, Arden needs
to know the creatinine level.
And to get it, this expression
must be interpreted by the EHR
in a particular hospital to fetch that
value from its proprietary database.
So, even though the purpose of Arden
is to share clinical decision support,
because EHRs aren't
readily interoperable,
we run into roadblocks like this, and
that's led to low Arden adoptions.
Healthy Decisions was a nearly two year
long standards effort sponsored by ONC,
and has now been folded into
a broader clinical quality framework.
It proposed using parts
of the Arden technology
along with web services designed to make
fetching data like this much easier.